you have a device for young people
in high school and college
you yourself
started from the humble beginnings in
brazil
maybe a bit of a wild risky decision to
go to japan
and now are the head of one of the
biggest most successful most impactful
companies in the world
given that story can you give advice to
young people today that
you know how they can have a career or
just the life they could be proud of
i think the first thing and i'm and of
course all those answers are going to
relate
to my own experience right um the first
thing
is it always work for me to have
to have a plan even if the plan is just
what i'm going to do within the next two
years but what do i want to do where do
i want to go
and
and i think it's important for people
especially young people um
is
is to really you know have a dream and
go pursue it i mean have dreams not go
back to bed to sleep it's really
what what do you want to accomplish and
then what it's going to take to do that
and uh and then believe in yourself um
you know i i like i said i joined
qualcomm as an engineer um and uh
i didn't have any plans when i joined uh
to be ceo but i do wanna as an engineer
what do i wanted to do what i where when
what where i want to contribute what i
wanted to work on and then and then keep
evolving from that point in time
the other thing is
this is an advice it's more of like
career advice that i got
i got early in my career was extremely
helpful for me and i will give that
advice to everyone that is interesting
um
spend time understanding what are what
are the things you're good at and what
are things you're not
like what is that real border between
your area of competence in your area of
incompetence and once you see that once
you see that you know exactly what you
have to work on and you can say i can if
i that's where i want to go next this is
the gap i need to do it and it's it's
it's faster when you can identify
yourself before other people can tell
you
then it leads to automatically the next
step
surround yourself the people that are
very good at the things that you're not
[Laughter]
so you have to be radically honest about
the things that you're not good at but
given what you're passionate about you
need to get good at or you would like to
get good at and surround yourself by
those people
how often did the plans you make
actually work out
so you said it's important to make plans
you didn't say anything about uh it's
important to execute on this more than
fifty percent yeah
that's right try to keep it above 50.
uh what was the whole why did you end up
in japan
you know i've been uh fortunate enough
to work in cellular and wireless my
entire career so i i always like
communications
when i went to engineering school uh my
dad was electrical engineer but he
worked with the utility company he
wanted to
me to graduate in traditional electrical
engineering like hi in energy generation
distribution um
and but i like electronics communication
so i end up doing both
and uh and i always like communication
was fascinated by wireless communication
so my first job at a college i started
working for a japanese company down in
brazil
was nec and within about a year in they
transferred me to
tokyo asked me to go to the headquarters
and
it was the first time i left uh brazil
and a little bit different from brazil
cultural different uh is uh in the other
side of the planet
and
and that's how it started
you